I know I'm going to get hate for this
segment
but it has to be done if I don't hold
progressives to the same standards as
conservatives what am i doing right I
agree with Alexandria Castillo Cortez on
many issues but if that excuses her from
critical analysis of what she's doing
and what she's saying I am doing a
disservice to everyone in the audience
and I lose credibility so I'm not
picking on her here I know that she's
new but no one is forcing her to say the
things she's been saying on Twitter and
during interviews she's a congresswoman
elect and she is now subject to scrutiny
I care so much about the progressive
movement that I don't want anyone
including her going out and saying
things that don't make any sense
now she recently tweeted that there's a
double standard that when Paul Ryan was
elected to Congress at age 28 everybody
called him a genius but people are
calling her a fraud for being 29 and
having been elected to Congress I never
called Paul Ryan a genius I'm not
calling her a fraud I'm merely analyzing
her statements the same way I would
anyone with the context that I agree
with a lot of reviews so please don't
lump this in with the irrational anti
AOC stuff that has infected the right
let's get into it
first problem AOC starts tweeting about
Medicare for all great full disclosure I
support Medicare for all there's a
number of very serious studies about how
it is that Medicare for all would save
us money in the net and if you ask right
now in the Democratic Party who are some
of the most prominent Medicare for all
voices voices in favor of Medicare for
all alexandria cassiopeia cortez is
probably one of them no doubt that's
great I agree with the policy but then
she goes on Twitter and says quote 21
trillion dollars of Pentagon financial
transactions could not be traced
documented or explained 21 trillion
dollars in Pentagon accounting errors
Medicare for all costs 32 trillion
dollars that means 66% of medic
for all could have been funded already
by the Pentagon and that's before our
premiums this is really dumb okay this
is this is silly her argument is we
don't even really need to worry about
what Medicare for all will cost because
two-thirds of the cost could be funded
from the missing money and accounting
errors of the Pentagon now it's true
that there's a ton of money in so-called
missing money but it's not money that's
missing in the sense that if you find it
then you can use it there's a major
problem here with the reasoning there
are transactions that are inadequately
documented by the Pentagon there is no
evidence that the money is sitting
around somewhere and could be used to
pay for part of Medicare for all this is
just the wrong argument in favor of
Medicare for all this is based on just
an incredibly simplistic
misunderstanding by the congresswoman
elect about what it means that the
Pentagon has lost track of money she's
sort of furthering the idea that the 21
trillion might be just somewhere and as
soon as we find it we can pay for 2/3 of
Medicare for all that's just not the
case we're talking about money that is
improperly accounted for or tracked or
documented these are accounting issues
they're not there's a pile of money
sitting around it's a really simple
mistake which she just can't be making
okay we have good ways to talk about
paying for Medicare for all this is a
way to self-sabotage Medicare for all
activism someone's just got to explain
it to her now somebody did apparently
later explain it to her and she followed
up Daffy after being criticized by
saying well I'm not literally saying use
the missing Pentagon money I'm just
making a comparison about how vien the
numbers being thrown around for Medicare
for all aren't that much bigger than
these so-called accounting errors but it
was too late the initial tweet got all
the attention and she was flat-out wrong
nonpartisan fact checkers have no choice
but to say this is wrong and this is you
know pants on fire for Pinocchio's
whatever scale they use and that's bad
for the movement that I support next
she gets into it with Donald Trump jr.
on Twitter now again full disclaimer I
like Alexandria Acacio Cortez I agree
with lots of her politics I find Donald
Trump jr. to be a disgusting human being
I think he's committed crimes for which
he will be indicted
but Alexandria Castillo Cortes messed up
again appearing to threaten to use her
political power to get back at Don
junior for making fun of her on the
Internet
Donald Trump jr. posted a disgusting
meme about Alexandria Castillo Cortes
which had a picture of her and said why
are you so afraid of a socialist economy
followed by a picture of Donald Trump
saying because Americans want to walk
their dogs not eat them now of course
both communist and non-communist
countries around the world sometimes
have the tradition of seeing dogs as
just another type of animal whose meat
we might eat it's not really a big
political insight right so far
Alexandria Castillo Cortez has the upper
hand she's been targeted in a disgusting
and stupid way by Don jr. but then she
tweets quote I have noticed that jr.
here has a habit of posting nonsense
about me whenever the Moller
investigation heats up please keep it
coming jr. it's definitely a very very
large brain idea to troll a member of a
body that will have subpoena power in a
month have fun big mistake
I get it Don Jr's disgusting I can't
stand the guy he's posting horrible
things I support the house using its
subpoena power for investigations but
this is an unforced error we don't
subpoena people for trolling online we
subpoena them because we determine that
they should be subpoenaed for
participation in potential crimes
knowledge about crimes or for other
reasons the mere implication Pat that
his trolling is something that might get
him subpoenaed is an unforced error
completely misguided and she really
shouldn't be doing this
yeah I think she absolutely should be
doing better here and maybe there's a
case to be made that we should have some
sort of
League right before progressives get
into the upper ranks of Congress they
should first you have some sort of
training maybe run for lower-level
offices so they can kind of build up
that repertoire and all that experience
there's certainly a trade-off here
because when you have younger
less-experienced folks in office their
fiery they're creative they can rally
people behind them but they're also more
prone to making mistakes and that's
what's been going on here yeah and of
course there would be no way to enforce
that farm League but I understand what
you're saying that when you are sort of
shoved into the limelight in such a
prominent and rapid way that this type
of stuff can happen and right-wingers
now we're saying she may have even
broken the law by doing this I don't
think she did but this is a completely
unforced and avoidable error and Friday
I'm going to deal with what she should
be doing but to sort of give you an
overview its media training and getting
more informed about basic economics and
history and sort of how government works
I mean there's no secret here she's
going to learn this stuff and I say this
all with peace and love lots of
attention is being paid to her I don't
want her damaging the movement I support
because she's making this miss these
mistakes which make her a target in a
way that is not necessary and his
counterproductive if you disagree and I
know many of you will let me know but my
criticism here is not an attack on her
it's because I want her to be a steward
of the movement in which we share so
many ideals period . that's my objective
follow me on instagram at david pakman
the show is also on instagram a david
pakman show quick break and then part
two of my interview with Zoltan Istvan
is coming up next